welcome back my next guest is Magic he's
one half of the legendary Duo Penn and
Teller a Global TV Superstar they offer
a new crime novel random and
pendulations great to see you good
interview with you many times never in
this studio it's great to have it really
nice first of all I want to talk about
uh teller your your great friend co-star
has just had 47 years big heart surgery
he had a quadruple bypass and I got to
tell you shook me up more than it did
him you know two days later he was in
physical therapy where where were you
when it happened uh he was at home in
Las Vegas and uh it's really remarkable
I as I was walking out of the he's in a
rehab facility where they're doing
physical therapy the all the nurses took
me aside and said we've never seen
anybody like him he's like a week ahead
of where he should be two weeks ahead
and I said well he's he's tough yeah but
he's going to be okay oh yeah there's
will be we'll be back uh end of November
and uh scary for you is this terrifying
terrible did you think for a moment you
may lose it well uh there was no reason
to think that but I thought that you
know what I mean all your fears go
through your head yeah well please send
him my very best I certainly will and on
behalf of all of the viewers too it's
great so much to talk to you about but
first of all this issue of Kanye West
what he tweeted being no platform this
whole issue of social media censorship
what's your view about it it all comes
down as usual to me being wrong you know
and uh I remember being in a seminar at
MIT at the end end of the 80s early 90s
talking about how when you'd had total
free speech and everybody had access and
looking at this as kind of a Utopia I
had never crossed my mind that we'd find
a way to to monetize
shock and hate and outrage and once
you've got those in their algorithms
that are in place to monetize that I
don't think of of course he should not
have said that should he be no platform
for it ah these are private
organizations they can take them off and
they probably should be morally do you
think is it the right call where do you
think that line with free speech and
hate speech begins and ends I think that
if you're talking morally it's
absolutely reprehensible and should
never be said who decides that it
shouldn't be said as a heart is a hard
issue but the real problem seems to be
much deeper in that we found a way to
reward that kind of thing and of course
with uh with our mutual acquaintance
Donald Trump we saw that that got
rewarded and rewarded rewarded you know
I don't care what they say about me as
long as they talk about me that was
always kind of nonsense but now it seems
very close to being literally true
should social media firms like Twitter
like Facebook like Instagram is awful
case of this young girl who was
bombarded with imagery about suicide and
depression because she was looking for
stuff about suicide and depression and
in the end the Court ruled that it ended
up contributing to her taking her life
Timmy seems to me it's a bit of a wild
west still you know when you run a
newspaper it's regularly you run a TV
show they're regulated but the the
social media is just completely Lawless
the whole uh the whole thing is uh
there's got to be a way to change it so
that that's not rewarded and I don't
think it's really tough to say we want
to have a board or a government doing
this but uh private companies I mean
Twitter can have anybody off there they
want you can allow anybody you want on
your show you can decide you're deciding
all the time in a way it's a form of
censorship by who you decide to have
enough yeah you decide you've decided
that 7.6 billion people won't be on your
shoulder what's going to happen with
your country in the next election is
Donald Trump going to run again should
he run again and would it be good or bad
for America we've actually really had
one candidate run for president while in
jail it was the Communist candidate in
in the right of the first world really
you can legally run in the United States
should Trump run again would it be good
or bad for America for America terrible
awful I mean we we worked with him uh
you and I I think that uh
many things we agree on uh some we
disagree on but Memphis agree on is he
was wonderful as a television character
but did either one of us think he'd be a
good president I never thought he'd be
present a million years
and in a way you know his instincts were
pretty good the rhetoric was a lot of
the problem with Trump uh well what I
think was the problem was the complete
and utter lack of Shame yes and I don't
think he has a shame vows no no I don't
think he has an empathy valve or a shame
value I certainly got a little support
never heard him uh sincerely laugh at a
joke no it wasn't at someone's expense
yeah and more importantly uh kind of
poetically never saw him tap his foot to
music
did you ever see him like no but now you
mentioned it that is creepy I totally
agree really creepy talking to people
tapping their feet to music you you're
about to replace Simon Cowell on Britain
yeah
you're far too good looking Japanese
Christmas oh Britain's Got Talent
sitting in fact probably in one of the
old chairs I used to sit on as a joke
yes yes and it'll be uh uh a two-hour
Christmas special all magicians and I
think I know all of them so it'll be uh
it'll be wonderful because they uh they
really shoot magic very well yeah and
I've seen the list of who they have on
and they are wonderful brilliant well
it's it's strange isn't it how our
Worlds Collide uh I've interviewed you
around the world you're now going to be
judging the show I judged for four years
and it's great to see you and I will try
to fill your shoes
good luck Miranda the book oh thank you
sir here is great it's great to see you
and send all our very best to celebrate
I certainly will good to see you